plus les choses sont condensés rétracter
et plus
finalement elle se manifeste dans leur
totalité sensuelle et ça c'est
applicable dans tous les jeunes femmes
le spectacle art et alors c'est pas
parce que on montre pas carrément tout
qu'est-ce que c'est pas fabuleusement
tout
et justement c'est difficile moi par
exemple j'ai une scène où j'ai mon drap
blanc et un moment je fais venez près de
moi en seul il est assez large pour nous
deux il ya un univers
il n'y a pas besoin d'aller plus loin et
puis ça a choqué les enfants éric sets
serrés showcase de moules parce que on
va tout le temps vous offre un max milo
mais je sais ce que fabrice est en train
de quoi il en avait parlé d'une certaine
perversité donc normal de voir ce que je
veux dire ce que nous voulons dire à
perceval
c'est un film c'était une tout public à
ce moment là
arrive un peu bébête non mais en fait
d'autres ce n'est pas un film noir six
blessés pas un film qui peint des
aspects sortie de l'existence le comme
beaucoup de films
il dit d'ailleurs souvent le fond avec
une crédence vérité c'est un film dans
lesquels tout ce qui se passe et bien et
montrer de façon pour envoyer un mot de
l'époque de façon courtoise et attrayant
rapidement dans les moeurs au maillage
et qui apparaît précisément dans ses
romans qui est de l'autre côté c'est
possible mais en fait dans les romans
les romans de chevalerie qui était fait
pour des femmes pour des lettristes sont
des romans extrêmement délicat et cette
délicatesse des on la retrouve aussi
dans l'art dans la nature
on la trouve dans la musique ah c'est ça
que j'ai voulu montrer autre chose